ces logements ne sont peut-être pas très
grand mais pour zurich une chasse à
maria terrils qui vivaient dans la rue
c'est un espace où elle se sent enfin à
la maison et en sécurité sur glace
j'ai peine à y croire dit elle je me
réveille dans un endroit
et peu importe la taille j'ai de
l'intimité c'est qu'en plus de contenir
deux liés d'être climatisé et chauffer
ses raisons de 6 mètres carrés se
verrouille de l'intérieur et de
l'extérieur
vous n'avez pas à vous inquiéter que des
gens entrent par effraction et prennent
vos effets personnels
trois autres villages sont installés sur
des terrains vagues ou d'anciens
stationnement los angeles
la ville a acheté quatre cent soixante
six petites maisons préfabriquées
elle coûte entre 5 et 9 mille dollars
américains et s'assemblent en 90 minutes
c'est l'organisme heroes of the valley
qui s'occupe de la gestion des sites
il ne s'agit pas que d'offrir un toit
aux personnes sans abri mais aussi un
véritable filet social et tous ses
services qu'il s'agisse de santé mentale
de soins médicaux d'accompagnement pour
dépendance se poursuivront avec eux
quand ils trouveront un logement
permanent
ces villages se veulent une solution
temporaire une transition entre la rue
et une maisons permanentes les origines
sa soeur maria théorie compte bien
saisir cette chance à demain pour
repartir à zéro ici alexandrie bel et le
radio canada montréal